[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000.
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i'm going to be taking you
through
some of the many immortal chess games
that have ever been played
so uh i want to start with with the
first one despite the title
you know we are going to take a look at
a lot of the spin-offs here
but it all sort of started way back in
the 1800s
with the original immortal game the
immortal
game so i felt like we should at least
very quickly go through the first one
see where all the hype
came from and see if it helps put see if
it helps put these spin-offs into
context
so to start with we of course have adolf
anderson
against lionel adelbert the gracie and
felix
kaiseritsky okay so
adolf has the white pieces and in true
you know 19th century fashion
we're going to look at e4 e5 f4
e takes f4 you know what what other
romantic opening is so iconic as the
king's gambit accepted
so in this game anderson plays bishop c4
uh kaizeritsky
decides to play the most combative
queened h4
check of course this variation forcing
white to move the king early early on
and then we are going to immediately
stray from modern
chess theory with the move b5 and
interestingly in the lead chess database
here there is
a game between nigel short and gary
kasparov
in rapid chess that also featured this
move b5 but couldn't find too many other
games here
so why you know why b5 or why not b5
well
it seems to sacrifice this pawn to get
the bishop off this long open diagonal
but we'll see that perhaps the uh you
know tempo gaining threats that black is
able to make
are perhaps not so severe and so just it
just ends up not being the greatest of
pawn sacrifices
bishop takes b5 by whites kazuritsky
plays knight to f6
now knight f3 is immediately pushing
this queen back
we see queen h6 and then anderson
calmly you know points out the bishop is
opposite the queen
and is hoping that this will result in
some fun tactics uh
in the meantime by the way this is where
nigel short decided to differ and shows
knight c3 in this position but nothing
too crazy
so d3 by anderson now knight h5
by kaizritsuki is immediately starting
to create some threats
taking advantage of this queen back here
on age six
and it turns out that despite being the
mortal game anderson did not play chess
perfectly
very few people did uh ever and
especially in the 19th century
that that would be a bit rare so it
turns out that the proper way
uh quote unquote to deal with this would
be to simply develop
uh and ignore the threat just allow
knight g3 check to happen and knight
takes h1 because knight
d5 is going to be such a strong move
with counter threats against the black
king
or alternatively just simply
sidestepping with the rook rook to g1
and then despite the king being stuck on
f1 it's actually not the
the least safe square in the world for
the white king
in the game though anderson chooses
knight to h4 to combat the threat so now
of course
knight g3 can be met by pawn takes
because the knight is interfering with
the queen's access to the rook
queen g5 played in the game and now
knight f5
is the follow-up for anderson just
planting the knight on a super strong
square
uh and here is sort of black's last
chance to uh
well actually not the last chance to
have an advantage uh black still
plays pretty calmly and pretty
reasonably with c6
but now we're going to see that this is
where
uh the i'll the whole idea of b5 is just
a little bit
uh flawed by playing c6 you are yes
threatening to capture this bishop on b5
but it turns out this threat
isn't actually severe enough to warrant
a full response by white and that's what
anderson sort of relies on here
so rather than move the bishop away
anderson offers it up
as a sacrifice after g4 hitting the
knight
knight f6 and simply rook g1 saying okay
you can take my bishop if if you want to
and kaizeritsky says yes okay i'll take
your bishop
so what's wrong with that what's wrong
with taking the free bishop
well it turns out that this pawn is very
very important to keep control of the d5
square
and this is going to be a decisive
factor in the actual game
so much better here for black was
highlighting the point
that this knight is a little bit stuck
well actually something like g6 is a bit
too late for
g6 could have perhaps been played
instead of c6
but after this point rather than capture
uh we need to to solve the issues
on on the king's side of course g6 is
actually quite a bad move here because
because of h4
but h5 would be the trick and then you
can simply tuck the queen back away
and if any trades black is doing
perfectly fine in this position
remember white still owes a tempo over
here eventually black will be able to
capture this bishop
instead though we see c takes b5 now h4
hits the queen
we get queen g6 h5 queen back to g5
and now queen f3 makes a threat and
unfortunately now
uh there's no turning back for black we
see
knight g8 played by black just
no real comfortable way to save this
queen so we have to give it an escape
route
we see bishop takes f4 queen f6 now
knight c3
and it's pretty clear that this d5
square is the issue now
for black bishop c5 played at the game
now knight d5 hitting the queen queen
takes b2
and then interestingly bishop d6 which
leads to
the immortal tactic that ends the game
but actually is perhaps not so good it
turns out that after queen takes a1
black is able to perhaps escape with a
perpetual check here
at first glance a computer will say that
like black is totally winning
but i think after king e2 it is most
likely a draw
for example just for some moves
um queen to b2 king to d2 is actually an
important nuance
bishop takes on g1 and then e5
and somehow you end up in a draw here
with threats on all sides of the board
for example check queen over and i don't
want to get bogged down in all of these
complications because none of this
happens in the game
instead we see bishop takes g1 and that
is going to be the end
of the game for black simply e5
now interferes with the queen's access
to the king's side
queen takes a1 king e2 super safe in the
middle of the board
uh by the way take my rooks anybody okay
aside from that
knight a6 knight takes g7 king d8 and
then if you haven't seen this tactic
before
i would encourage you at home to try and
find the checkmate here
of course the move is queen f6 and
bishop e7 checkmate and that's your
immortal game everybody goes home happy
anderson's a champion just sacrifice all
the pieces take my rooks take my queen
checkmate
easy easy peasy uh
but there are a lot of games that sort
of resemble this game
somewhat and as such have been named
similarly
so i wanted to start with the two most
closely related games i'm going to claim
which are the immortal losing game in
the immortal
drawing game so these two games are
going to share a lot of similarities
to this you know classic immortal game
that we see
here but you know with with their own
twist on it in true spin-off fashion
so to start with i want to take a look
at this game
between bogdan sliwa and david
bronstein and i definitely didn't
pronounce that one right but that's okay
so we start with d4 and f5 so wildly
different start
than the previous game obviously not
going to be a kings game it accepted
but then again this is the immortal
losing game which is why we're looking
at it
from the loser's perspective uh okay so
g3 g6
bishop g2 bishop g7 and so far so
reasonably normal it's just sort of a
weird offbeat line
in the dutch but it's nothing too crazy
right both sides getting developed
and white just choosing a rather
non-aggressive fiance variation
knight c3 played in the game knight f6
bishop g5 and both sides just sort of
casually complete development the only
real thing of note here
is that black has neglected to move
either center pawn for some time now
uh that being said it's nothing you know
no no great crime against chess just yet
but white should probably enjoy a slow a
slight advantage just because black
is so vacant from the center we see
queen d2 and then black does play the
move d6
in early h4 by uh sliwa a little bit
ahead of his time here
this h4 move is really gaining in
popularity in modern chess but we do see
it in some of the classics
and now e6 by bronstein so bronstein is
going for one of those hyper flexible
setups where he's not committing to e5
or d5 just yet uh and really he can do
anything with the pawn structure
from this point forward queen side
castles played by
white in this case and now h6
forces the decision from this bishop it
calmly
retreats back to f4 we see bishop d7
and then white decides to break in the
center with e4
and this is really the the problem i'm
going to claim with the super flexible
but uh perhaps lacking in space setups
that bronze scene decided to go for here
the issue is just that white has a
little bit too much freedom in the
center of the board
and is going to enjoy a little bit of an
advantage because of it
nothing too crazy though as i keep
saying in the game we see fe4
knight e4 and knight d5 yeah and like
yeah white is slightly better
but nothing too bad 92 by white
finishing development
queen e7 by black is a slightly strange
move just clearing the back rank
and again keeping options open for the
king but now white does find
a good move in the form of c4 and this
sort of forces black's hand
black really does need to sort of gain a
tempo here by capturing
on f4 because after the move played in
the game
white actually has a really great move
here to put the pressure onto black's
position
so white to move chat room see if you
can find a good move
for sliwa after bronstein's knight to b6
see if you can find a good move for
whites after knight to b6
what do you think chat and yeah there's
actually two conflicting ideas
and it makes sense that these two ideas
come to mind right away
uh manny in the chat says c5 and pieman
says
d5 and now we have another vote for c5
so yeah these are the moves that you
should probably be looking at and the
reason for that is pretty simple
black's king is stuck in the center you
have a lot of active pieces in the
center
and a battery waiting to come down the d
file so you should be looking for ways
to open up the position
with the pawns and my cursor was just
magically traveling i don't know if you
guys saw that that was crazy
but okay so c5 and d5 are definitely the
moves that that come to mind you want to
open things up in the center
and this is the way to do it as for
which move is correct
well you do want to take advantage of
this sort of dark square
attack you've got going on so definitely
c5 is the move
and this is the move that's this is the
reason why knight takes f4 was a bit
better to avoid this sort of
uh tragedy then uh knight takes would
attack the g
pawn and against c5 here black would be
able to shut things down with d5
and again this is sort of the problem
for braunstein you have this super
flexible pawn structure but you don't
have any time
to you know take advantage of the
flexibility by moving it with d5
because your pieces are already under
attack so from here white just is
already a bit better we see d takes c5
in the game really the only option
but now bishop takes c7 is quite good
and at this point bronstein is already
on the back foot we see kingside castles
but white now chooses the simple bishop
d6 which is simply picking up the
exchange
uh queen f7 bishop f8 rook f8 and so
you know bronstein's on the ropes right
he's he's down
you know in exchange he's losing all his
center pawns the opening has been a
disaster
but now he he flips on the jets he turns
on the jets in the fourth quarter
and he's he's like all right i'm just
gonna checkmate the guy
you know i'm down material it's time to
checkmate the guy i'm gonna play
my immortal game i'm gonna sacrifice all
my pieces
checkmate this guy he never saw it
coming and so to start with this we see
white playing d take c5 capturing the
material
sort of playing the role of kaizeritsky
in the first immortal game just taking
taking taking
and now we see bronstein playing knight
d5
and what starts uh sort of as
some position where black just looks it
looks entirely busted
we start to see pieces sort of gather
around the queen side
near white slightly exposed king
in the game seliwa plays the move f4
which is a
very good move the point is to sort of
stunt all this pressure down this f file
as well as just
gain more control over the dark squares
in the center and the king side
now we see bronstein play rook to d8s
again you know sort of sort of saying
okay
all right i'll start by by cutting off
this file from the white king
white king's not going to escape that
way and then after knight two to c3
we just see the swarm sort of begin we
see bronzing play knight d
to b4 saying all right all right i'm
going to control some of these squares
going to control some of these squares
and now i'm going to control some of
these squares
and it's starting to get a little bit
scary if you're the player with the
white pieces here you may be up in
exchange and you may have
a lot of control of the center but
black's pieces are starting to get
really active
and if this is like a blitz game then
then
it's a little bit unclear if white's
king is going to to live to tell the
tale of this game
that being said white is doing great
still finds the great move knight to d6
and now queen to f8 and now
i want to see if you guys will survive
the various traps that bronstein has
has set in this game so white plays the
move knight takes b7 as i think many
people
naturally would and then we see the move
knight d4 and the threats
are uh are rising in the position so
chat room first question can you play
the move knight takes d8 here
first question can you play knight takes
d8 or does something bad happen to you
knight takes d8 or no your opponent just
played knight d4
trying to corral your king
all right the chat room is conflicted
manny is pointing out a tactic
involving knight takes a2 and knight b3
something to look out for to be sure
but henry perhaps
didn't see the tactic or saw past the
tactic because yes knight takes d8 is in
fact the correct move here and it's what
white ends up playing
the problem with knight takes a2 is that
if knight takes a2
we do have knight b3 check gaining back
the the queen at the very least even if
white does have a lot of pieces still
but just king b1 is going to be simple
enough here
and then uh white is still doing just
fine
so instead of you know queen takes d8
like a
you know normal person just sort of
throwing in the towel or knight takes a2
going for a tactic that doesn't work
bronzing says hey that's fine i didn't
need that rook
i didn't need that rook i'm going to
checkmate you with my minor pieces and
plays bishop b5
so chat what's the move here bishop b5
do you take this piece do you take
something else
do you defend your king
white to move here chat room are you
still navigating
the traps are you still navigating the
traps
so yeah queen c5 on the previous move is
like
it's just not enough right it's just not
enough there
it doesn't really make a threat like
knight takes a2 i guess is the threat
but it doesn't do enough
so this time henry says don't take it's
a trap and in this case
i think henry's instincts are favoring
him again
knight takes b5 perhaps is a playable
move but you are very very close to just
being
entirely busted after the incredible
move
queen f5 and the point now is that
this uh sort of subtle idea of knight
takes a2 and knight b3 that we had
earlier
is now a checkmate threat rather than
the threat to you know just win a win a
queen or something so if knight back to
c3
we actually just have knight takes a2
here in knight b3
with the check mate not just check
and so uh queen five would be a very
nasty idea to have to deal with
that being said um all hope is not
actually lost here for white white
actually does still have a path to save
the king
but knight takes b5 a very clever trap
set for uh
for uh seliwa by bronstein notably the
natural move perhaps b3 just to try to
you know give the king some space get
out of here also doesn't really work
because queen takes c5 is going to be
quite strong
if king b1 simply knight takes b5 and
the king is very much stuck on the b1
square here and is not going to be
living to tell the tale unfortunately so
what move does save the game for white
what move does save the game
does the chat room know this one
all right i'm not going to wait too long
relying a little bit heavily on the chat
here
but the incredible move bishop d5
actually is one of the
only two winning moves in the position
and this is the most unnatural one
so what is the point of bishop d5
well the point is you don't want to draw
the queen away from our threat
because then white is able to capture on
b4 and by the way if white tried to
capture on b4 of course this is
checkmate
so you don't want to move the queen away
because then your knight hangs
and you don't want to move the pawn the
knight away
because then again you are removing the
threat of knight takes a2 and white can
capture your other piece
and lastly if pawn takes on d5
now b3 is playable because there is this
nasty interference
where black can no longer take on c5 and
no longer has this winning idea
uh and because of this incredible move
bishop d5
white is actually still winning now that
being said there is another option here
which is to play queen f2
and then after queen takes c5 and king
d2 uh white again
would be on the better side of things uh
black can take this piece
on b5 but white is up enough material
here that after
a move like bishop e4 or queen f1
starting to take back
some of the light squares uh white is
going to be winning
uh once again so knight takes b5 perhaps
a bit of a mistake
putting yourself in hot water so instead
we see knight takes e6 by sleigh one not
falling for the trap
and now bishop d3 in create an
incredible move by by braunstein what's
the point of bishop d3 well
it's the same idea as queen f5 we're
gonna go knight takes day two and knight
b3 and dare you to stop me
so of course knight takes queen would be
a big blunder
due to the checkmate but of course sliwa
calm cool collected just plays bishop d5
says
i'm going to defend these light squares
you're not going to check mate me
so bronstein turns up the heat once
again plays queen f5
and is just entirely swarming the white
king
but sliwa finds another accurate move
here knight takes d4
and now after queen takes d5
of course we're not going to see the
move knight takes d5
when this is checkmate in one but
instead
sliwa just plays the simple knight c2
pretty nice move here just taking
advantage of the pin
of the bishop on the d file and ejecting
this knight
and with this move the attack is
essentially over
uh bishop takes c3 was tried pointing
out that queen ticks is met by knight
takes a2
and after pawn takes we saw queen takes
a2
c takes b4 and finally out of pieces
david bronstein decided to throw in the
towel and resign here
down a full two rooks in this position
so this is the immortal losing game and
it's been given this title
because braunstein had all the heart all
the you know tactical tricks of the
immortal game
but uh in this case just lost all his
pieces
and lost the game which is sort of what
happened more
more so in the 20th or the 20th century
compared to uh
the 19th century wait yeah the 20th
century
19th century that's correct 1800s and
1900s confused myself for a second
so we have the immortal game where you
know white sacrificed all the pieces
and won easily we have the immortal
losing game where black sacrificed all
the pieces and lost easily
now what is the mortal drawing game how
do you have an immortal drawing game
uh well it's pretty easy you know one
side sacrifices all their pieces and
then the the players agree to a draw so
let's take a look at it this one comes
from
uh carl jumpe and philip
meitner two chess players not really
known for much else aside from this one
game of chess that they played but that
being said
this one i think also happened in the
19th century so
uh if if their names are still being
tossed around today clearly they did
something right here
so let's take a look at this one we have
e4
e5 knight c3 bishop
c5 and knight a4 what is white doing
wasting time in the opening attacking
this bishop on c5
so of course how should black respond to
knight
a4 early on in the opening
what should black do
so of course black should play bishop
back to e7 what are you crazy what did
you think
did you think i was gonna say bishop
takes f2 bishop e7
is uh generally agreed to be the best
move in this position you just retreat
the bishop
and you have yourself a normal game
eventually white's gonna ask himself
why is my knight on a4 you know it
attacked a bishop one time but i guess
i'm just gonna move it back to c3
eventually
and everybody goes home happy you play a
normal chess game but
philip knightner did in fact decide
bishop takes f2 was the way to go
so now we have king takes f2 and of
course the follow-up is queen to h4
check and now we start to see that
perhaps the sacrifice
isn't as ridiculous as you might think
because
if the move g3 were to be played queen
takes e4
actually causes white quite a bit of
trouble here
for example if bishop g2 a perfectly
natural move or even queen f3
then the the you know the knights
hanging and this is a problem right
so this move knight a4 actually actively
working against white
uh and so if something like uh
queen e2 queen e1 uh saying if you take
my
knight then i'm going to take your pawn
then black can actually
snap on the h1 square and be a bit
better with extra material
so no turning back now for white
you've accepted the extra piece you
should play king e3
defend your pawn your pawn's attacked
your king's in check
move the king defend the pawn what more
is there to know
uh so the follow-up to this is of course
queen f4 check
and now king d3 so with the black pieces
here we'll actually flip to the black
perspective because it's a bit more fun
with black how do you continue right now
you're running a
one woman attack with your queen you
need more pieces
so where do you get the pieces out
the venerable game six-year-old versus
seven-year-old the incredible thing
about this game
is that yes there are some moves that
are not ideal
the game was played in 1870 of course
but the players
their moves are actually logical they
make a lot of
you know intuitive sense and they're not
the worst moves on the board
nine times out of ten so wow there's
actually a lot of differing ideas here
b6 is a big one knight f6
b5 has been said and d5 has been set so
of those moves you want to always play
sort of the most ambitious the most
attacking and that one is going to be d5
in this case you want to still take
advantage
of this knight hanging loose on the a4
square you want to open up your bishop
and you even want to just open just rip
things open you know use the pawns to
attack use the pieces to attack
use everything you can to attack so d5
is going to be the best option here
and the point of d5 of course is that
this move is sort of ridiculous black is
just going to take the piece and be much
better because your king's on d3
and there's no good way to defend this
piece if you play something like queen
to f3 simply d
takes e4 and if you take back there's
going to be a bishop f5 follow-up so no
good way to defend e4 here
so with that in mind we got to run the
king
and they're gonna take on e4 you gotta
get out of there dude you gotta get out
of there queen takes e4 is coming
you can't just get checked you know
after queen takes e4
so king c3 best move clearly
um and now uh queen takes e4 is played
just inching forward with the black
pieces and by the way
maybe like in modern day chess now we
can like cheat with computers maybe like
d4 is a slightly better idea
for black to kind of maintain the
balance here
i don't know i didn't do the super
in-depth study of this line
but queen takes e4 is has been sort of
the accepted move to keep the attack
going
and now there's actually a fairly
ridiculous move
for white to just see as the advantage
kings on c3 knights on a4 no pieces
developed aside from that
but white can actually seize the
advantage with the incredible credible
move d4
just much at the same as how black
played d5 to
launch everything into the game white
should play d4 to to get the
their own pieces activated and the idea
here is that after
takes on d4 queen takes d4 there is this
tactic with queen e1
but now white is happily going to
sacrifice the rook
on a1 in exchange for having
all of white's pieces developed and
suddenly none of black's pieces
developed
and a largely safe queen and the follow
up to this
is going to be that queen takes g7 is
coming very quickly and is not an easy
idea to stop for example
something like knight f6 is going to
mean bishop b5 check
and disaster so you have to sort of deal
with this
something like knight c6 where queen
takes a2
but then queen takes g7 and white is
gonna be a bit better here
queen a4 queen h8 and there's actually
no way to uh to save this knight king f8
is always met by bishop h6
and it's a sad sad story so d4
incredible move for white but of course
you know carl hampe he's good at chess
he's not that good at chess
she plays king b3 says all right i'm i'm
gonna keep running dude you keep chasing
me
i'm gonna keep running i gotta defend my
knight and my king is looking loose
so king to b3 that's the idea
uh and now in order to stop d4 black
should probably
actually play something like d4 or
knight c6 uh himself just just to
prevent this idea
and continue the the flow of the pieces
but instead in the game we see knight to
a6
instead and this is where uh this is
probably the worst move of the game to
be honest
white definitely should play the move d4
here just play d4 get the pieces in the
game
and get some defenders around your king
instead
white tries to move a3 and the point of
this move is pretty clear
white wants to run and hide why it's
done white's like okay
i'm bailing you know my king
it's it's been a fun journey but i'm
gonna i'm gonna hide on a2 now like
that's that's the idea
so chat room unless you've seen this
game before
if you've seen the game before don't
cheat but black to move here
black to move how to continue
how to continue
what rating was this played in well it's
the 1800s which i think predates
uh pretty much any rating system but
these were i think two
reasonably high level chess players of
the day
now it is the 1800s so none of them are
you know competing with magnus but uh
they are pretty good
all right chat rooms full of morons what
are you doing
developing your pieces what do you think
this is do you think it's the immortal
game because there's no immortal i
developed my pieces game
okay there's no immortal i developed my
pieces
think bigger think bolder
d4 than bishop b6 so
d4 is the move that stockfish wants to
play at depth 25.
which is terrible white has an advantage
it's like plus point eight
stops trying to play like stockfish play
like a genius
pieman says sack everything and colin is
the first person i see with the correct
answer
whether or not um you know it was their
original idea i don't know
but of course now everybody sees it
queen takes a4
get rid of that knight that knight on a4
that's been the whole point we've been
trying to take this knight we've been
inching closer and now finally we get to
capture the knight for free
so of course white plays king a2 and
loses or
king takes a4 accepting the challenge uh
and now the trick for black is to
somehow keep this king from going
backwards
and still come up with checkmating
threats so the way to start
is pretty clear it has to be knight c5
if you do any other sort of check the
king can just
come back to the hidey hole on a2 so
knight c5 to start with
now king b4 now how should we follow we
gotta keep the attack flowing
gotta keep the main threats coming how
to continue
well of course we should continue with
the move
developing a piece no a5 check gotta
play boldly gotta play the the forcing
moves here
and now the idea is that after king to
c3
incredibly i think uh i think black is
actually
winning in this variation which is sort
of ridiculous
uh the winning variation goes d4 check
king c4
bishop b6 check king takes c5
and then incredibly knight f6
and uh your checkmated buddy your
checkmated i don't know what to tell you
got your king checked mated here um if
you do nothing something like queen f3
for example you're gonna get hit
with knight to d7 this was the threat
and we've pretty effectively put this
king in a box here
so king b5 only move now
c6 and b5
check is actually not mate but knight c5
is checkmate bishop does cover
so bishop b5 check is the better try
but then incredibly the winning move
here
king e7 you just get out of the way just
get out of the way man king e7
in black is winning for example queen f3
b6
and of course the only winning move rk7
why not rook a7 you got to defend the c
pawn and deliver checkmate to the king
okay but enough of this king c3
variation okay who's playing king c3
here this is the 1800s this night's
hanging
it's not defended black's a [ __ ] free
knight
free knight so of course
priority number one for black is
ensuring this king does not escape our
mating net so we
that means blocking off its access to
the d5 square
which is why we see 97 played in the
game now we do see bishop b5
check by whites desperately giving
himself a defender
and of course black to move here the
only move
is king d8 that's right the king's
getting in on the action here we need
this king
to defend this this pawn in some lines
otherwise it's never going to work
it's just never going to work so king d8
and of course bishop c6 only move by
white only move bishop c6
uh what happens if you don't play bishop
c6 well i'll tell you what you get
checkmated that's what happens
so uh also for example any other move
like
you know bishop a4 for example is
running into checkmate in this direction
bishop
e8 for example is sorry
running into just capturing it and then
the same threats so bishop c6 is the
only idea
now of course we need to continue with
b6 check you know we're not gonna get
out of this game
by playing b take c6 it's surprisingly
impossible to check this king on c5
this knight is two diagonal spaces away
which makes it
really difficult to give a check this
bishop attacks on the light squares
we ran out of pawns and it's pretty
tough to get a rook over there
as well pretty tough to get a rook so
that would be losing so of course b6
check
and king to b5 and now the final uh
testing move well not one of the final
moves that you have to find
black to move here black to move
and find the draw
bishop c6 who invented these studies
these two players they played the chess
game
bishop c6 only moved by white only move
so bishop a6 check the problem with
bishop a6 is that you lost sight of your
mating net
right you're trying to put this king in
a box but the king
is finding an escape route gotta be
careful gotta be careful
bishop a6 but how do you stop the king
from running
how do you stop the king from running
away
okay a4 has been suggested i don't know
off the top of my head what the problem
with a4
is ah the problem with a4 is that you're
gonna lose a rook
rooks are powerful we may have
sacrificed a queen
in half of our other pieces but stroke
is too much
we need this wreck
so it's not quite as simple as a4
because after you lose this rook this
bishop is still going to be on the board
and one defender against this many
attackers is just not
not a good combination there you're not
going to have enough
so exquisite corpse actually has the
right idea we need to play knight takes
c6 here surprisingly
and now the idea is that after king a4
we can actually cut the king off
from the b3 square with the move knight
to d4
and believe it or not this is just force
checkmate bishop d7
is impossible to stop the king is
completely immobilized
no matter what you play here bishop d7
and bishop b5 just easy easy win
um queen g4 is b5 check by the way
so don't think you can stop it by being
super clever uh probably you can
actually just take this as well
and come back but anyways enough of that
uh and the reason by the way why this
doesn't work here
is that again bishop takes eight is too
much and you've lost your defender of
the the a5 square
on top of that i think other moves like
d3 are working
because you're just a turn too slow with
your b5 idea
if you take this guy i take this guy and
this is
highly illegal so knight takes c6 the
only way
but then but then i don't know if you
guys realized this night's hanging
knight's hanging so one more move to
have to find here
one more move to find what is it
what can you do and yeah mourizhov
already has the idea
bishop b7 check and this is our
perpetual check
draw repetition uh king takes b7 is
actually going to be winning
for black after the idea king e7 no not
king e7 king d7 cutting the king off
and putting it in a big box with rook g8
coming
now you might be thinking to yourself
wait a second this move is check
but of course king d6 no more checks
king is safe this king's still in the
box no way to stop rook h to b8
and you know this one may not end up in
yasuo sarawan's
take my rooks book but it does end up in
the take
all of my other pieces book if if this
were to have happened
that's where it should go and the book
titled take
literally all of my pieces besides my
rooks uh but of course this doesn't
happen
because white does not have to take on
b7
that is one bishop too many to to
capture you know
the white king may have captured every
other piece but that bishop that's just
one too many
so king b5 is played instead and now
without the bishop on c6 bishop a6 check
is good enough if king a4 were to be
played now bishop c4
and b5 are enough for checkmate so king
back to c6
and of course here we need to stop the
king from escaping out to d5
and bishop here is just a little bit too
much because
now we have no way to actually attack
the king and white's gonna get the queen
in the game
and just sacrifice it the first chance
that that he gets
and that'll be the game white white
would win so
we have to go back to b7 and now you're
beginning to see the picture here
and the game is agreed to a draw so
that's the immortal draw
and those i think are sort of the big
trifecta
of immortal games you have the immortal
win you have the immortal losing game
and you have the immortal draw uh but of
course there are tons and tons and tons
of more immortal games and i did have
one more
that i wanted to show you here tonight
uh this is going to be
the immortal zugsman game so you've seen
the immortal win the immortal loss
and the immortal draw but now it is time
to branch out uh away from
chess results and into just chess
concepts because
why not name every game in a mortal game
so this one is going to be between one
samich
against nimzovich so two titans of the
chess world
in the early 20th century and uh this is
a game that actually gets featured
in nimzovich's uh infamous or famous
book depending on who you ask
my system but taking a look here we
start off fairly normally with
uh fairly normally with nimzovich having
the black pieces
we get e6 knight f3 and a queen's indian
defense
white ops for ethi and keto we see
bishop b7
challenging this bishop before it ever
arrives bishop b7
knight c3 castles castles
and d5 so so far so reasonably normal
again
i think a main move here is knight e4
but d5 perfectly
acceptable move right just challenging
the center
normal stuff uh white ops for the move
95 here which is fairly common
uh you'll see this in a lot of queen's
pawn openings white just occupies the e5
square early on
because white has time to do so by
virtue of having the extra first move
uh now black plays the move c6 which is
not really the most common
uh generally blocking this bishop off
from this diagonal this early is not
ideal
uh a huge point to this opening is that
black gets good control
over the e4 square and with c6 that sort
of abandons that concept
and white can usually get a a pretty
solid advantage by taking over the e4
square here
and there's a ton of lines that you can
analyze at your leisure after e4 but
white should be a bit better
in this game though sameach plays much
more simply with c takes d5
and c takes d5 now this has the effect
of
closing this diagonal forever and making
this bishop look a little bit silly
on b7 but it also has the effect of
you know giving back control over e4 to
uh to black
and so this really shouldn't be giving
black any any problems
bishop f4 is played in the game and
nimsovich just starts to expand a little
bit
with a6 intending the simple b5
rook c1 played in the game now b5 to
follow and just gaining some
space on the queen side of the board we
see queen b3
and now knight c6 by nimzovich and
uh samish now plays a move that sort of
readily admits
that the opening has not necessarily
gone his way
so this last move queen b3 i think is
actually a pretty bad one
because knight c6 no faces you with this
awkward
decision of what to do with the pawn on
d4
and it also might make you realize that
knight a5 and knight c4
are sort of coming so white plays the
move knight takes c6
and this is really never a move white
should be happy with in
the these kinds of openings because you
can just sort of count
the uh count the moves each side is made
white has made one
two three moves to trade these knights
black has made one two and you basically
just lose a tempo
and activate this this bishop for black
that is all that you really achieve
by taking on c6 and this is an idea that
actually shows up in in many different
positions where
if you're the side moving your piece all
around maneuvering it across the board
and then you initiate a trade you're
usually not the happiest about it
so black completely equalizing here we
see h3
by white just a sort of waiting move but
in this case it doesn't help all that
much and might end up hurting
the position as we'll see queen d7 and
white continues to play very very slowly
with king to h2
as for a slightly more active idea
perhaps
white should be rerouting this other
knight over to the e5 square
just to sort of do something because at
the moment white is really doing nothing
we see king h2 in the game and now
nimsovich opts for
knight to h5 hitting this bishop on f4
white retreats the bishop back to d2 and
this is sort of going to be the
character of the game now
so this is a really instructive idea uh
that i want to highlight from this game
because
obviously these games are immortal
because they're really really fun to
look at
but i do think that this idea of the
knight on h5
is one to uh to take note of especially
for your own games right the last few
games
sort of so crazy there's not too much to
take home
as far as lessons but in this game
knight h5 this is going to
really influence the rest of the play in
the game
um at you know reasonably high levels of
chess
having a knight sidelined having any
piece sort of out of play
for a prolonged period of time is pretty
bad it's sort of game losing i think
last week i analyzed a game where a
knight was stuck on a4
and that was essentially what what lost
the game for for that player
in this case it's going to be a battle
of deciding whether or not this knight
on the rim
is actually you know dim or grim or
whatever have you
or if it can be a really nice attacking
piece
so we're going to see nimesovic trying
to prove that the knight on h5 is useful
and white's uh samish on the other hand
should be looking to prove that this
knight is sidelined and is not useful
and if it looks like it's going to be
useful white should drive it away
so in the game we see black immediately
playing the move
f5 and this is in direct relation to
having this knight on h5
yes perhaps uh some days uh nimzo is
thinking about bringing this knight to
the e4 square
but even more importantly it's looking
to sort of team up with this knight on
h5
by playing f5 f4 launching an attack on
these dark squares that the knight is
pressuring
and this by the way is perhaps another
reason why
h3 is a bit ill-advised uh
now again white should probably be uh
starting to reroute this knight and slow
down some of this pressure on the queen
side
but instead we see queen back to d1 and
i think this is just a really
poor game uh positionally by sameach so
far like h3 king h2
queen b3 queen d1 knight f3
knight e5 knight takes c6 just not
leaving the best impression
uh nimso continues now with b4 forcing
the knight back to b1
and while you know a while ago i was
talking about this maneuver being
something active
for white to try to do at this point
it's a bit too late a bit too much time
has been lost
bishop b5 now for black and we see that
by taking on d5 so many moves earlier
white has locked in his own bishop and
black has found a way to activate
using this extra space on the queen side
rook g1
now by samish unpinning we see bishop d6
and black is essentially saying i'm
going to play f4 on the next turn and
rip open your king's side and you're
going to be totally busted
so sameish not one to roll over quietly
finds the really active idea
of e4 and the point here is that
samish is finally saying hey i don't
like this knight on h5 i'm going to
attack it
not only am i going to attack it but i'm
going to use this tempo
to sort of rip open the center so black
to move here
what do you think nimzovich played chat
room what should nimzovich do here
what should nimzovich do
and then great wolf has a question from
earlier which i i will actually circle
back to
if i remember i about half the time when
i say that i forget which is
always nasty so nobody has the answer
knight takes g3
is reasonable but but actually not the
best way to sacrifice the knight
um f4 again i guess reasonable trying to
to give up the knight for this this pawn
on g3 but still not the best way to
sacrifice the knight
nimsovich finds the best way which is
with f takes e4
and the point now is that you get this
pawn in the center
you get control over a ton of these
squares and you also actually
still get to break down these these dark
squares thanks to rook takes f2 all in
exchange for the night
knight g3 only really manages to uh to
take off this pawn
and after e5 you might find yourself
regretting this idea
as far as f4 i think here this is just
not
not as much this pawn on e4 still lives
and you're not getting any any material
actually for the piece
so that's a bit a bit worse so f takes
e4 the best way to do it with rick takes
f2 to follow
but yeah you guys are correct in
thinking you have to sacrifice this
knight like
knight f6 is just like so sad and e5 is
a problem anyways
so f takes e4 the queen takes h5 rick
takes f2
and now queen g5 by uh white just trying
to defend here
and bring the queen back into the play
of course rook a to f8 just bringing
in more pieces and king h1 which is not
a move
i fully understand by uh
samushir i think samish is just trying
to stop rook 8 to f3
making use of this pin so king h1
unpinning trying to defend this square
but now rook 8 f5 hits the queen
and bishop d3 which just really locks
white into this awful awful position
uh now rook c to e1 played in the game
and black to move here everybody black
to move see if the chat room can find
the winning move in this position
black to move and win the game
great wolf says king h8 and he's close
he's close but that's not the move that
black decided to play there's actually
one more
useful move that black can play and yeah
everybody has it
everybody has it so the last useful move
for black is
h6 and the point now uh of course this
is the immortal
zugzwang game and so you should have all
been looking out for the position
where white's in zugsvang and this is it
white is
totally and entirely zugged
in this position there is no way to
improve the position
and in fact most of white's moves here
lose the game on
the spot white can try and
pass for for maybe a turn or two with
something like a3
black can actually just shore up the the
pawn with a5 and maintain the position
for example takes takes and once again
it is going to be white's turn
white can pass again with something like
b3 i believe
but king h8 and now it is
once again going to be going to be
white's turn
you can even play something like h4 but
once again simply king g8
is good enough and the point uh to
circle back to this position
is that yes white can uh sort of
try and pass with the pawn moves but
eventually those are going to run out
black can do something even as simple as
move the king back and forth
and any piece move literally any piece
move is going to be
disastrous for white so let's sort of go
through them one by one
why not king h2 passing you know trying
to hold the position well
the problem with that is it steps back
into this pin that we talked about
earlier in brook five to f3
is now going to be winning the game the
queen is entirely trapped
and you have to just sacrifice it for
for a rook and then
you're kind of zugged again almost not
entirely but almost
so k2 is out same thing with g4 here if
you play g4 rook 5 to f3
the bishop can no longer take because
this is checkmate with the bishop
um why not bishop c1 well that hangs the
knight on b1
why not rook c1 well that hangs rookie
two when again
the queen is entirely trapped uh why not
anything to f1 well
you know this is just hanging a piece
and why not
h4 and bishop h3
well once again that is going to to hang
the queen
leaving it totally trapped why not any
knight move
well there are no knight moves rook d1
also loses to rookie too
and that's that's that there's no more
moves
white is in zugsvang so this is the
immortal zug position
where just despite having all but one
minor piece on the board
white is entirely strapped for moves and
just
cannot do anything just cannot do
anything forced to resign
and samish does in fact resign after the
move
h6 so this is the immortal zug so so far
we've covered
the immortal game the original one the
immortal uh
losing game by braunstein where
bronstein sacks all the pieces and loses
in great fashion we have uh the immortal
draw
by carl hompe and philip knightner and
now we have the immortal zug
by samish and nimzovich so i do want to
go back into this game great wolf had a
good question earlier on
uh after knight takes on c6 bishop c6
there is this nice
little um discovered attack idea and
white can sort of try to make use of it
with something like knight a
knight e4 knight a4 actually doesn't
work because this is a tempo
but knight e4 is playable but once again
black is going to be doing totally fine
here white has some activity
but black's going to get an extra pawn
so just for those curious about
this uh little tempo here after knight
takes c6
that's what was going on and aside from
that there are actually some moments
here
when um white should be able
to sort of save the game a little bit
this knight h5 and f5 idea by nimzovich
actually perhaps isn't the best uh
perhaps a bit better
was just to immediately start launching
uh the stuff on the on the queen side
just advancing these pawns
and taking a bunch of extra space after
f5
white should in fact be looking to evict
this knight something like bishop f3
is perfectly fine here followed up with
bishop f4 and white is at least fighting
back in
in the center of the board uh and so
that's really where samish goes wrong
like even after h3 and king h2
white is wasting a ton of time but isn't
entirely lost just yet
uh it's just the fact like queen d1
knight b1
you know these kinds of moves all these
retreating moves rook g1 and then
following this up with the e4
it's just asking a bit much you can't
play six nothing moves in a row
and then say i'm gonna play the glorious
e4 and free my position
it's just asking too much of the
position as many famous commentators
often say so any final questions for me
before
uh we we call it a day here any final
questions
after rook f3 why not queen takes rook
f3 winning both rooks so okay
i will quickly just go over this final
tactic at the end
um anytime i was playing rook f3 it was
with
the pin here so we don't play rook f3
but but pawn takes f3 and you only get
one of the rooks
uh same thing after g4 if you take here
i just take with the pawn
and once again this is the pin
but okay marshall lasker1925 was like
another immortal losing game
but this one was the official one i
looked it up it's got a wikipedia page
that's how you know that's how you know
it's official
um all right so maybe if you guys enjoy
this one i will do a follow-up uh
series with more immortal games there
are plenty to choose from
these i found the most interesting
because they were the ones not named
after just like a location or a player
instead named after just chess results
and eventually a chess concept with
zugzwang
but if you guys have any secret spin-off
immortal games that you don't think i
know about
feel free to leave a comment and maybe i
will go over some more immortal chess
games
in the coming road to 2000s hopefully
you guys enjoyed this first ever
tuesday edition of the road 2000 once
again there have been some schedule
changes i will always be on tuesday
nights now
please check our website for the full
details on that
and aside from that as always my name is
caleb denby thank you very much for
watching and i'll see you
next time
you